hey what's up people the internets
you're not going to believe this but
today
i've got a very special guest mr ian
kron
the um enneagram extraordinaire
i've got a lot to learn about this i'm
excited to grow i'm excited to learn so
we ready to go
i'm so ready let's do this okay so the
enneagram
you've made it famous did it make you
famous i don't know i'm gonna go with
you mit
you made it famous so in a
quick nutshell walk me through what the
enneagram is yeah
well the enneagram is an ancient
personality typing system
that that teaches that there are nine
basic personality types in the world
one of which we gravitate toward and
adopt and child it
as a way to feel safe and navigate
the world of relationships and very
importantly
it teaches that there that for each of
those nine types there's an unconscious
unconscious motivation that powerfully
influences how that type
predictably habitually acts
thinks and feels from moment to moment
okay
so does that typology get wired into us
biologically
or experientially or all of it all of it
i mean
let's face it kids are born into the
world with certain
biological and genetic wiring right i
have a child who was born anxious okay
some kids you know are born slightly
depressive right eor
types right you have other kids who are
born sunnier than
you know than a blue day in colorado um
so
there's that dimension okay then we have
familial and cultural impact
on the development of a personality
right so obviously
trauma little t trauma big t um you have
um cultural forces that come to us
through school through coaches through
teachers
through life experience and also
you know social context right like a kid
who grows up
in a latin american country may have a
different cultural experience than the
kid who grows up in asian culture values
differ and so those affect
okay how a personality is formed among
but as you know personality is one of
the most hotly conte
contested debates in all of psychology
that's right that's right so
how how young does someone begin
registering
a a pathway or a number
well i think that the building blocks of
personality are in place probably around
the age of five or
six okay but it's wet cement oh i like
that
you know okay uh and so i i recommend to
people that they don't start messing
around
with children in the enneagram until
they're in their
adolescent years and later adolescent
years because as you know
lots of adolescents try out a new
personality every week just to see how
it goes
i know and i know grown-ups that do that
as well as well
okay so before we get into some of the
the deeper questions
um i'm so excited to have a fellow is it
a bad if i call you fellow nerd i'm so
excited about this
i'm a total makes my heart feel good um
walk us through those nine types
okay um is there a way to kind of 30 000
foot them i think so i'll do i'll do my
best okay cool
so ones are called the improvers and
their unconscious motivation
is a need to perfect themselves others
and the world and just about everything
they do right okay
twos are called the helpers their
unconscious motivation is a need to be
needed
loved and appreciated by others okay
threes are called the performers they
have a need to succeed
to appear successful and to avoid
failure at all costs
fours uh are probably the most
complicated number on the enneagram
they have a need to be special and
unique in order to compensate for what
they perceive is something lacking in
their essential makeup
okay okay fives are called the
investigators
they have a need to collect and gather
information
about everything particularly a niche
subject or two
okay in order to fend off feelings of
inadequacy and overwhelm
yes right okay uh in the world sixers
are called the loyalists
their own unconscious motivations and
need to feel safe
secure and supported in what feels like
an unpredictable
and chaotic world to them okay sevens
the enthusiasts the joy bombs of the
enneagram
their unconscious motivation is to
sidestep
or avoid psychologically or emotionally
distressing thoughts and feelings by
living in a future
filled with unlimited op so
optimistic possibility okay aids are
called the challengers
their unconscious motivation is a need
to assert strength and control over the
environment
and others in order to mask feelings of
vulnerability
and weakness and then finally the nines
are called the peacemakers and their
unconscious motivation is to
avoid conflict okay maintain connection
and preserve a sense of inner hakuna
matata
you know tranquility peace it's all good
man
go with the flow don't rock the boat
yeah okay
so i took this your assessment over the
weekend
i prepped for this and it surprised me
it came back that said
i was a two
strong weak wing one right
tell me about myself yeah so as i
mentioned
one of the wonderful things about the
enneagram is it's not like a regular
trait system
okay right which only tells you what you
do
okay but one of the things that the
enneagram does is it tells you
why you do it okay which is really
really important yes
right yep now just so you know you
actually are all nine numbers
okay tell me about that well you contain
all nine numbers you everything i just
described you could say well i do that
sometimes i do that sometimes
right you do contain all nine numbers
you just have one that's dominant
okay that you just click into by default
by
all of the time but you have access to
the energies and resources of all those
other types
it's just you specialize in one
and is that a and again that's just a
cocktail of
experience and genetics and
yes my family and but most importantly
this um it's this
little bubble i've created to protect
myself from whatever system i was
thrust into yes systems yeah
yeah so as a two right as i mentioned
your unconscious motivation is the need
to be needed
okay uh and to be loved and appreciated
by by others right right
um that can be great yeah
[Laughter]
that's the good thing right uh you all
are the warmest
um i say supportive
generous kind people who create
naturally create environments
in which people feel safe to tell their
stories
and to be themselves you're the kind of
person who at the at the airport gate
someone will sit next to you
and you'll just be sitting there reading
and they might just turn you go i'm i'm
getting a divorce
you know what i'm saying and you're like
oh you know
like there are other types that do not
get that kind of you know
interaction with people but twos kind of
have what i call
a um sort of a wide
circle of concern for other people you
know what i mean like people just
feel this radiating sort of concern for
them
here's the dark side the downside is
that often
to the care and the health that they
give to others is calculating and
manipulative
okay because what they're really looking
for is
the love and appreciation that they get
from others
for helping them so it becomes kind of a
a
pipeline it's like it's where you put
the hose in the tank you know it's like
i need love and appreciation i need to
be needed by others
okay so it can come with strings
attached right
like i will do this for you
so that i will meet your needs so you
will meet
my needs without my actually having to
come right out
and say i need some support and
acknowledge that i have needs
ah okay right like like twos if you say
to a two
what do you need a two will go i'm not
quite sure you know what i mean yeah but
you know what everybody else needs
and that's in a sense why you have so
much trouble knowing your own needs is
that you've been so exquisitely attuned
gotcha almost psychically got you to
other people's feelings
that you've lost touch with your own and
what where does that
like distill down where does that what's
that defense rooted in
well you know i think sometimes children
who are twos
uh grow up in situations where they've
had to step in and become the caregivers
right or they have a natural disposition
toward
being a kid who's just very kind and
warm and generous they get stroked like
heck for it
gotcha to the point that the kids
thinking you know
if i just overdo this
i'm going to get even more strokes right
yeah
yeah and then after a while you know
personality
largely is made up of adaptive
stratagems and
and you know ways of coping in the world
ways of showing up in the world and
getting our needs met
right so someone another twos get
a message growing up like if i want to
get my needs met
i gotta meet the needs of others so my
dad was
a swat hostage negotiator
and in the city of houston so when
things were quote unquote going down
i i have these distinct memories of him
he'd get this little cockeyed grin and
he'd put his
bulletproof vest on and put a suit on
and
i just have these images of him driving
the other way while everyone's leaving
he's going in and it was just this like
and he was a homicide detective
and then he left that job about halfway
through my life and became
a really an atypical minister at a large
church
because he had this police background
but he had this this
i would call this underbelly sensibility
he knew how the systems worked and
people would kind of come out of the
woodwork to get his help and support
right and so i grew up with this idea
that when things go down
you show up and you step in that gap and
then you do things nobody else will oh
there's a dead body in there i'm going
in that room too right
right um someone's has a question about
sex
i'll answer that question right and you
yeah it becomes a it becomes an identity
so i resonated when i read this
right um what is the
so you say uh so you say the dark side
is um
i can go searching for it yes and
looking for people to solve
or looking for people to inject myself
into
yeah sometimes it can become smothering
okay it can become smothering
overwhelming well you could become
over-generous
to where it's weird or freaks people out
yeah you know um
or step into situations there's a
we always say that there's a deadly sin
or passion associated with each of the
nine types okay
and tell me how i'm gonna what's my
deadly sin it's pride
okay and what the pride is is that
for twos they begin to believe that
they're more attuned to what others need
than
that person ah yeah okay okay so
that's where the pride shows up it also
shows up in the
the two secret belief that others are
more needy than they are
okay and that they are the only ones who
really have the answer for that person's
problems or need right so
they kind of they make great therapists
right
okay tons of tons of therapists or twos
and partly because
they're just they have like this radar
it's like they can zero
right in on what the other person needs
and what the other person
feels they know what you feel before you
do
you know what i'm saying yeah yeah so
it's a great it can be a great gift
right but it can become a great
liability if what you're expecting is
for the other person
to meet your needs in return for
your meeting theirs without your having
to
acknowledge you have needs gotcha
there's another piece of the pride
walking through walter just waltzing
through life thinking
i have crested any sort of need yeah
it's also
it's also this the pride shows up for
the two
in their belief again unconscious belief
that they have all the time
treasure talent and resources to meet
the needs of everybody
no that's my great if i had to distill
down a couple of great sins of mine one
of the big ones would be
um completely
dismissing this idea of time and
resources right so i say yes to
everything yeah and then i find myself
overwhelmed
and then i get pissed at the person for
having asked me as opposed to
yes like how dare you take my time or
what a favor i'm doing for you
yes that's how you know you're in
trouble right right is when resentment
is aroused
that's exactly right so the resentment
is look at this is when you're in a bad
space
all right look at everything i have done
for you i always show up for you but
when i need help
no one's there for me gotcha that's
sometimes where a two will go right
and when they do it can get kind of
aggressive right which is unusual for a
two that's usually warm
and affable and amiable okay you know
what i mean so what's a strong wing mean
when it's uh i'm a strong wing one or a
wing
four what does that what do those mean
okay so you have two numbers adjacent to
your dominant type
okay your wing can only be one of those
numbers so for you
it would be a one right or a three you
can't be a two wing six
okay or a two wing seven you can only
those two numbers on either side of
yours can be
your dominant wing one of those two okay
okay
it explains a little bit why two two
people the same type can look
very very different so a two wing three
would be far more
ambitious than a two-wing one okay a
two-in-one would be
more introverted than a two-wing three
okay uh
a two-wing three would be more likely to
be
um out there in the world very much more
comfortable in front of crowds
things of that nature a two-wing one
would be a little bit more disciplined
organized self-disciplined
and a little bit more of a critical
thinker than a two of the three wing
okay um you are in what's called the
feeling or the heart triad
okay you are the most interpersonal of
all numbers if you're a two
there's no number that you go to bed at
night thinking about relationships
and you wake up in the morning thinking
about relationships if you're a two
yeah those that's what matters to you
more than anything else right
but isn't it the most important thing
though right
well in balance here we go with balance
it's it's um
yeah because i think everything's about
relationships and so i would i would
suggest that the other eight numbers
need to catch up
well which is i guess i'll let them know
let them yes so
when i am doing good when life is um
humming along what's what is what things
do i need to be conscious of
well as you know i think i'm a big carl
young fan okay
right young is the biggest influence
i've had in the world of psychology
when you're doing well you are operating
with a degree of self-awareness
where all the unconscious stuff beneath
the waterline
of consciousness right is just
continually being brought into the light
right that's one of the great things
about the enneagram the enneagram
doesn't just tell you why you do the
things you do
uh it doesn't just tell you what what
the things you do are it tells you why
you do them
right that's the material that's in our
unconscious okay
right and that's really important to
know yes right
just knowing what you do i mean you know
that that congratulations that's the
goal
that's right that's like applause right
yeah so
you know i think the more self-knowledge
and self-awareness you can get in your
life the better off you're going to be
you know
i always like to say that ignorance is
bliss unless it concerns
self-awareness right right so one of the
one of the great critics of
of a union analysis is
that people know what's down there then
they weaponize it
they use it for their benefit they can
they use it against other people
they can um tell me why
so i'll get meta for a second we've had
more
we're going to take in fmris and take in
more psychological inquiries we've had
millions of people suddenly become
mental health
scholars and researchers and
practitioners
and it feels as though the
world has spun itself sideways
and now i want to say that in a causal
way
but i've had to be reflective over the
last six or eight months and wonder
is some of this stuff were we not
intended to dig into some of this
do the solution-focused folks have it
right
what's the problem let's solve this
problem let's get to tomorrow
i'm not going to say they're wrong i
think different people benefit from
different modalities
i agree i agree right yeah and and some
from a sort of an eclectic approach
right
drawing on cbt solutions whatever it may
be
um i i'm of the school that says the
more you can know about yourself the
better off you're going to be yeah
me too right yeah and and the more that
you can integrate that material
the better off you're going to imagine
okay right so
one of the things the enneagram does
that i love and we talk about this on
the road back to you is
that it it shows you how your blessing
is your curse and your curse is your
blessing
right it tells you that in your shadow
they're not it's not just bad stuff in
your shadow there's beautiful stuff and
carl young called it the golden
the golden shadow right which is all the
stuff that
you picked up as a kid that were
things about you that the people around
you the important people
around you seemed real or perceived to
not
think we're good that were actually
beautiful about you
that need to be retrieved it's had a
light shine on it right
yeah you need to bring it back out
there's stuff that should stay in your
shadow there are animal
impulses and instincts that need to stay
in your shadow
there's some beautiful stuff in there
that needs to be brought back out and
revealed to the world which is often
happens at midlife when people say
you know i feel like i've been living
off the wrong script for the last 40
years
i think i left something behind
childhood i got to go in there and get
it
and bring it out and start to use it in
the world so how do you
what's the filter by which you decide
that needs to stay
and this needs to be seen well i think
if you have an impulse to hurt somebody
or yourself you know what i mean or
something like that that's an impulse
that probably needs to stay in the
shadow
it's there yep trust me you know and i
know that people
commit crimes all the time crimes of
passion where something
popped out of the shadow you know with
that needed to remain there
my dad used to tell me you know as a as
a murder detective
man the difference between me on the
side of the table and that guy on that
side of the table
it's that big yeah opportunity it was
this yeah yeah sure
circumstances yeah right um that we're
we're all
much more similar than we're comfortable
believing we are yes
so really what the enneagram does in all
honesty
right this isn't um a deep psychometric
like and i don't want to confuse your
audience like but like an mmpi
well so let's let's do that real quick
before okay you're about to tell me what
this is
so i want to take the skeptical view go
for it i've been through
i was one of the first folks to take the
strings finder back in the day
um i've rolled my eyes at the myers
briggs for years and it's just last
two or three years come out that it's
kind of mostly made up
um and psychometric after psychometric
right on top of
i've become a vocal um antagonist
against
our obsession with mental health
diagnostics right you are
like anxiety is not a disease it's a
code but it's an insurance it's an
insurance code right
it's not a way of being it's not an
identity it's not a disease
so how does this differentiate from
what would be yet another diagnostic or
yet another code
okay so let me just before i answer that
and remind me the question in case i go
off okay
here's what i would say i tend to
believe
what robert box the great statistician
said he said all models are wrong but
some are useful
yes i love that right so honestly
the enneagram strengths finders this
right
they're models they're wrong the
question is are they useful
are they true enough right that you can
benefit from them
and i would argue that the enneagram is
wrong air quotes but useful it's
close enough so what you get from this
is nine low resolution pictures
of the interior world of people and how
they move through the world
it's not perfect right but
it's if you even got 10 percent more
clarity about your wife your child your
you know colleague right you would be so
more greatly advantaged in your ability
to
to relate to them that it would be
amazing
yes just 10 more this was not a low res
on me
like i think i told you off air like i
felt like i was sitting outside and i
took this on my back porch right
and i felt like i was suddenly standing
on my back patio with no clothes on yeah
it's pretty good
it was real good um and i'm a highly
skeptical person yes
um and it was real good well and what
distinguishes it from those other things
right these are not diagon these aren't
diagnoses right right these are
descriptions
right these are sort of just a pastiche
or you know a
collage right if you will that helps
people
understand why they do the things they
don't want to do
and you know don't do the things that
they want to do
does that make sense well and that's
where it was more i
i felt it more useful right so if i go
to a doctor
and i'm having a bad week and they slap
general anxiety disorder on me that's
going to be about
duration and acuity right and if i go
read strings finder it's going to say
you like to maximize things that's
static right
this tells me when you're leaning this
way this is where
yeah to get back this way this is where
why you're leaning this way in this
moment
this is the history of why you're
leaning this way yes and here's what you
can do to lean
the other way it recognizes the
enneagram does a great job of
recognizing that the human personality
is adaptive and fluid the way your
personality is functioning
right now would be a whole lot different
than if you were in a hostage
negotiation
right your your personality as and as
you know
the moment you meet a personality that
is rigid and cannot change from
circumstances circumstances
that you really are in the presence of
somebody and logistically you feel it
you just know it right yeah and you also
know that there may be a presence of
real pathology that's right some kind of
personality disorder that's really
grabbed hold
right so in my mind again
you know what the enneagram is for
garden-variety neurotics
i don't think so i think it's more
important than that really i do
okay um this
felt like it can scale meaning it gave
me tools for myself yes i didn't have to
go to somebody else
to then clarify this and then spend
seven years with does that make sense
absolutely um it feels like a coach
could walk me through this
and let me ping pong back and forth and
almost as a bowling
bumpers as as opposed to a right
um a clinician as a doctor
yeah i always say as a therapist that if
i'd had this when i had a private
practice
that it would have saved me two years
per client that that's it
yeah because it gives them some things
that yeah i love that and a vernacular
for the two of us yeah
so tell me about this book here man
wrote back to you man it is a
great if i say so myself but i'm very
proud of it in this sense that's a great
introduction or perimeter to the
enneagram most of the books on the
enneagram are about 600 pages
and they're quite technical content rich
but not something you
you have to quit your day job to read
right i can tell you that everyone in
this
ramsey organization god almighty dude
there is like the bible bible and then
there's the road back to you
man for real everyone yes see they're
all
yes the yes this is the book man the one
to get in on it
i love that you're talking about people
swan dive in the deep end of a pool
sometimes and it doesn't make a lot of
sense
right so that is a wonderful primer it
just it just helps people know enough
about the endogram
that it can move a needle positively in
their life if they choose never to read
another book on the enneagram again okay
okay that's really basically all i
wanted that book to be and then if it
sends you down the wormhole into the
more
technical deeper material that's great
too
but it doesn't it doesn't require you to
okay
and we've got 30 seconds left yes give
me one thing that's keeping you up at
night
as you you've sat with thousands of
people right
um you've spoke to thousands people
what's one thing right now that's
keeping you up at night and what's one
thing that you are
deeply optimistic about um i think
and this is a an obvious answer but i
think the current social and cultural
times that we find are in trouble me
greatly
you know uh for reasons we don't have
time to talk to but i think for all
you know regardless of where you are on
the spectrum of politics or social
beliefs
if that's not keeping you awake at night
then there's something really you're
neurotic
yeah you you really are living in denial
um something i'm really optimistic about
i think we could really
kind of emerge from this pandemic as
wiser
people not to diminish any of the pain
suffering and death that's
been associated with it i think the time
that we've had to spend in solitude
and with ourselves could
a product of it could be more
self-knowledge compassion
empathy and self-awareness
what a gift yeah i think that that could
be fantastic
that's awesome all right so where do the
internets people people of the internets
where they find you
well you know what they can do is they
can take that ieq 9 test
yes if they go to ian morgan cron
i-a-n-m-o-r-g-a-n-c-r-o-n.com
and actually plug in your name as a
voucher code john delaney
awesome they'll get a 20 discount so
please do this
your neighbors deserve to have you do
this you deserve to have you do this
your family your loved ones your
communities
it's an incredible from a skeptic
this is legit um go to ianmorgancron.com
thank you so much for being with us
thank you folks for being with us and
we'll talk to you soon